i saw an absolutely shocking statistic
yesterday on the internet for the first
time in history there are more us
citizens with a crypto account than a
savings account if we take a look 24 of
u.s citizens are reporting that they
have crypto accounts but only 23 of
citizens are reporting that they have a
savings account this study was conducted
by morning consult a global data
intelligence company now of course when
you look at this data the first question
you have is why how is that possible
well you've got to understand the
problem with savings in america 25 of us
citizens report having no emergency
savings at all they literally have
nothing that could actually cover an
emergency expense 26 percent of
americans report that they don't have
enough emergency savings to cover three
months of any sort of cost and so if you
add those up almost 60 percent of u.s
citizens either have no savings or don't
have enough to last for 90 days the fact
that u.s citizens are reporting that
they have crypto accounts and not
savings account isn't as surprising with
that backdrop u.s citizens just don't
have that much savings but if we go
ahead and we look at something like
bitcoin bitcoin is savings technology it
allows for somebody to actually go ahead
and put their economic wealth into an
asset that is technologically engineered
to not lose its purchasing power
remember the u.s dollar has lost 98
percent of its purchasing power since
the creation of the federal reserve the
u.s central bank but bitcoin is 180
degree difference it's a programmatic
monetary policy it's decentralized no
one controls it no one can create more
of it no one in the world has the right
or the ability to actually debase your
currency when you save in bitcoin here's
a chart that shows you exactly how many
addresses now this is the total number
of addresses so you expect it to go up
over time but as we've seen since about
2014 2015 we have been in a mass
adoption phase
i expect more and more people to be
adopting bitcoin over time now let's go
back to that study that actually showed
that more people have crypto accounts
than savings accounts when respondents
were asked if they or anyone in their
household owned the following back in
december 24 cryptocurrency 23
certificates of deposit 31 brokerage
accounts and only 14 robo advisor
investment accounts crypto is not only
big it's growing incredibly quickly so
when we take a look at the actual
cryptocurrency ownership distribution
you can see that the global average has
gone from 22 to 24
from july and august of last year to the
end of the year in u.s canada argentina
brazil colombia mexico france germany
spain uk australia and singapore more
and more people own cryptocurrency today
than they did just six months ago the
only two places where respondents
actually participated in this study that
saw a decrease in crypto ownership were
china and japan whether we're talking
about the western developed world or
developing nations around the globe
everyone wants crypto everyone is
adopting bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
and so of course we are seeing a
generational shift out of u.s dollars
and other fiat currencies out of savings
accounts and into the best savings
technology that's ever been created
bitcoin's inevitable and this is just
more data that supports the thesis that
bitcoin is still growing quickly and
we're all probably underestimating how
big this will get hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time